yo let me ask you this working with Paul
Pierce when it when he when he went live
because I was watching that [ __ ] when he
went live and it was the it was amazing
it was it wasn't it was amazing because
I was like because I remember like being
like 21 22 DJing in Scottsdale Paul
Pierce would always be at the club
having himself a good time great guy
like
but I remember all this great Energy
Great energy but I just remember seeing
that [ __ ] and being like this is the
this feels like if The Boondocks was on
right now they would somehow parody Paul
Pierce being that like being at a house
party with strippers oh that's fun oh
that's fun you know but it's just like
it takes us back obviously
it doesn't get in the work Disney you
know what I mean like Disney is under
you know ESPN is on the Disney umbrella
so we always kind of have to be mindful
of that mindful of it you know what I
mean and although you know it was just I
think I just think it was just a lot at
once it was so yummy because I've had
conversations when I've renegotiated my
deal with ESPN talking about you know
I'm a cannabis Advocate I have a company
shout out to seven leaves thank you
shout out seven leaves sometimes I'm on
you know my Instagram smoking but I'm
also a coach or father all this kind of
[ __ ] I mean so I'm a bit it's a business
to me you know what I mean so I've had
to have those conversations but it was
just like Paul [ __ ] was just like a
perfect storm I guess of yeah a lot of
different things and unfortunately man
it it didn't end well